Bitcoin is probably levered NASDAQ
returns with like a call option on the
world Reserve currency that does just
kind of put it into a category by itself
and Bitcoin
maximalists you know from cycle to cycle
you you rewind four years ago and then
fast forward to today you know the
people waving the Bitcoin flag the
hardest
you did not get an upgrade on those
people over the last four years and you
can disagree with me about that you can
get mad at me if you feel that way I'll
take a step I'll take it a step further
for you you don't have to say
it all right guys bang bang I've got
Travis here uh I think a right place to
start is there a world where crypto
prices go up but crypto adoption does
not happen and crypto products don't
work like can we have something where
prices make people Rich products do not
solve user
problems yeah I mean I think that would
I mean I think we would
probably you know if you wanted to
answer that question exactly I think we
would need to sort of Define
quantitatively what you know adoption
looks like basically but I I think what
you just described is is probably my Bas
case for how this uh this coming cycle
is going to play out and that was what I
tried to lay out in this in this tweet
thread that went so viral that that you
reached out to me about in
response so what is that look like like
your base case is
what yeah I mean the name of the thesis
is a lack of pretense that any of this
does anything or will ever do
anything and I came to that conclusion
by watching how last year unfolded and
how it looks like this coming year is
going to unfold and comparing that to
you know prior years in the six plus
years that I've been in crypto
full-time and that's not to say that
there's you know it's my expectation
there's not going to be any adoption
that's not true um I think stable coins
continue to be the strongest product
Market fit in crypto history even
stronger than Bitcoin and I'm sure
there's some Maxis that are gonna you
know uh be upset about that but um I
think the just the the numbers and the
volumes and things like that would would
support that I mean it's kind of ironic
that a stable coin you know is like a
pseudo crypto right that it's like oh
we're trying to like get off the dollar
and this that and the other but it's
like what is clear the product with the
most demand is a digital dollar that
moves around you know kyc free and
settles very quickly um and when you
move away from stable coin
adoption uh it does not look to me like
this coming cycle is set up to be a
cycle for um you know Mass incremental
adoption I'm just not exactly sure where
that's going to come from um we had defi
summer in the 20 in 2020 um which you
know I wouldn't call it a flash in the
pan
but because I think that would be overly
detrimental I think what we learned in
hindsight is that the tokens associated
with
defi um have a value AC cruel problem um
and uh the next summer we had nft summer
in
2021 and uh nfts aren't going anywhere
but in my view their current form is
insufficient to kind of gain Mass
adoption and I think a lot of the hype
around uh nft Mania was also just a
function of the of the tremendous amount
of money printing that the government
did and people were just you know there
was wild speculation across a bunch of
different asset classes but but I I I
actually struggle as we sit here
today to look into the coming cycle and
see where even the amount of hype that
that we got from defi summer or from
nfts is going to come from I mean there
are places you can look in you know AI
people put AI out there a lot um dpin
people talk about dpin a lot um it would
be my base case and this is certainly
not Financial advice nothing I say here
is financial advice but it would be my
base case that a basket of AI names
would outperform the broader crypto
Market over the next 12 to 18 months it
would be my base case at a basket of
dpin names would outperform the broader
Market Market over the next 12 to 18
months but I would not expect um you
know it would not be my base case that
the tokens pumping in either one of
those sectors would come along with you
know Mass adoption that ends up being
sustainable through cycle that drives
you know a value acrel through cycle you
know I think it looks like they'll
probably pump to the High Heavens and
then pull back you know 95% like we've
seen so many other alts do for multiple
Cycles historically so let me throw a
couple of ideas out there at you uh
interest is driven by macro in the sense
that uh the pump the you know um kind of
uh Behavior If the Fed was If the Fed
wasn't easing we would be having a
completely different conversation yes
and so if they do ease to any degree of
severity is that just uh crypto becomes
a play on global liquidity and people
Now understand easing equals asset
prices get separated from fundamentals
get long Get Loud have a blast on you
know X and chill and so like that is
interest is actually has nothing to do
with crypto it all has to do with
macro yes yeah that I mean I definitely
start from there for sure um and it's
part of you know the thesis in my view
because you know Bitcoin has a unique I
would say more Tim tested and well
understood and well Justified
relationship to macro and to Global
liquidity and the way I would
characterize that is that in my view
Bitcoin seems to be purpose-built
to sort of absorb an outsized share of
central bank balance sheet growth M
money supply growth so if you're if
you're bullish M2 money supply growth if
you're bullish central bank balance
sheet growth that Bitcoin is kind of
purpose-built
to capture you know some sort of
multiple on the growth of of of of those
global liquidity measurements
and you combine that and you know we're
going into an easing cycle fed's you
know highly likely to cut it you know at
least a few times this year I don't
think we're going to get QE this year
but I think they will stop tightening
the balance sheet at some point this
year and uh looks like China is you know
probably needs to ease a lot this year
as well too and um you combine that with
uh getting spot Bitcoin ETFs which
unlocks uh safe access to bitcoin for
trillions of dollars literally trillions
of dollars that didn't previously have
it you combine that with the having and
to me that looks like a pretty you know
what I referred to in the Tweet thread
as a a a free walk to all-time highs and
we can have a separate conversation
about how long it's going to take to get
there or how far beyond prior all-time
highs I think we're going to go but this
move from mid 40s up into the high 60s
looks pretty straightforward to me
because of all those reasons I just said
and and there is a mimetic reflexivity
that comes into play here and it's it's
this meme of three up one down you've
seen this three up one down yes right
that's it's really strong I mean that is
a strong Meme and there's a lot of
reflexivity that goes along with it
we're in the meat of the good part of
the three up one down right now like I
said you've got these these other
factors that look supportive so then
people take the next step to mtic
reflexivity and they go well eth BTC ran
last time oh eth's about to get a spot
ETF as well too so it looks like eth
probably has a pretty straightforward
walk up to to all-time highs and it's
like oh and then last cycle all these
alt ones ran relative to eth so you know
that's probably gonna happen again oh
and you know dog coins had a good run
last time so that's probably going to
happen again and so on and so forth so
it's just like it's a good year there's
there's such strong reflexivity around
this view that it's a good year to be in
the casino regardless of what the kind
of
underlying adoption fundamentals are for
what you're gambling on in the casino so
a second idea what if crypto is actually
just the greatest video game ever
created and what I mean by that is you
know you and I when we were kids we grew
up playing Madden uh NBA 2K uh maybe
You' play 007 on Nintendo 64 Sonic the
Hedgehog on Sega Genesis right we had
all these games and it took up an
enormous amount of time for us as we got
older many people abandoned the video
game
uh but replaced it now with Twitter and
crypto and so much of uh that attention
is driven by what are the little points
going up or down right on on these
screens what's the latest narrative
where can I find the quote unquote cheat
code and rather than having to put up up
down down right left you know circle
triangle on the video game controller
now it's basically like can I find the
telegram group where someone's going to
tell me about the next coin that's going
to pump and so there's this very weird
thing of like the gamification of
society continues to happen uh and so is
this just the greatest video game ever
created and that is quote unquote a use
case or an adoption driver is it is
about speculation it is about gaining uh
a game not so much you know how many
transactions or what is the the product
Market fit of one of these
products I agree with that um yeah I no
no I I completely agree with that and I
think you know one thing I would just
say is like I didn't really get into
this for that and that would be
disappointing relative to my hopes and
expectations for this technology in this
asset class and it's like I run a crypto
fund it's called eeky guy I named it
eeky guy for a reason probably most
people are familiar with this concept
you Google it you see this Vin diagram
what you're good at what the world needs
what you deserve to be paid for what
like to do you find those four things
you find your eeky guy it's like this
this what the world needs concept well I
I you know in the summer of 2017
convince myself that the world needs
this technology and that it does have
the potential to make the world a better
place and it can do it quickly it can do
it in a single generation and I think
that
the the gamification of society Trend uh
is strongly present I think it would be
like a Fool's errand to uh you know
think that that wasn't going to happen
or to try
and you know I don't know spend all your
time fighting against that I think that
would be um you know you would just you
just wouldn't probably get very far um
because I think it's an offshoot of this
is it's an offshoot of financial
nihilism which is a concept we can
probably talk about later I I I think
what I say is
that what I see in the crypto Market is
that that that gam this gambling on
vaporware
mentality
is becoming so strongly present in
crypto that it I think stands to present
serious risk of choking out the
potential for the technology ol to make
the world a better place like it's just
like there there's there's both there's
many things in crypto there's a
potential to make the world a better
place in these various different Avenues
there's and then there's lots of things
to gamble on and just have a good time
with and but but this thing over here to
me is getting so strongly present that
it could just choke out this other thing
which to me that would just be a very
disappointing
outcome is it any different than
traditional markets Nicola uh the EV
Company Rolling a truck down a hill is
that any different than someone uh
putting a partnership on their website
in the crypto sector that's not true or
uh people speculating on GameStop any
different than them speculating on Zin
coin trumpcoin or any other you know
token that they think could potentially
quote unquote make them rich like how
much similarity is it across these
markets and it's like a society Thing
versus it is a crypto Centric thing
uh I I agree with that and like I you
know the the underlying drivers of that
are you know and my a large part of that
is this financial nihilism concept and I
think is that explain Financial
nihilism um it's like I'm gonna put 500k
I'm gonna put
$500 into a
dogcoin that is probably going to go to
zero I'm probably going to lose money on
but there's a small chance that it could
50x because the $500 isn't enough to
make a difference in my life anyways and
neither is like ,000 doar and neither is
$5,000 and that's just because the
American dream is uh is unavailable to a
wider and wider swath of Americans
there's versions of that that are true
in other parts of the world as well too
um that upward Mobility that was
available
uh to the prior generation and the
generation before that it's not nearly
as available in this current generation
and then you know there's a host of
Statistics that that um you know support
this thesis but the easiest one is just
looking at median home prices relative
to median income right and and and where
that level is um and it just causes
people to make these different types of
decisions
financially and it's one of the you know
gambling in General roll is skyrocketing
and popularity skyrocketing popularity
and that is a function of financial
nihilism and gambling on vaporware I
mean dude don't get me wrong trying to
hit some low cap shitcoin and doing you
know research to go to go try and hit
some low cap vaporware shitcoin that is
in my opinion a much better usage of
your time than trying to put together a
five leg parlay on on pick a sport you
know what I mean like un unequivocally
so it's like you know but I think it's
it's
just you know and I'm not expecting that
all of that is going to you know that I
like want or expect or want to try and
work for all of that to get removed from
crypto that's not my point I think my
point is like the magnitude of that
attitude the magnitude of that attitude
being present in crypto and then what
does that mean for this Technology's
potential you know to F you know
fulfilling its potential you know to
make the world a better and have a you
know a positive outcome for a wide swwa
of
people so when we think about uh the
downsides I think you're spoton in terms
of that is becoming a bigger sector uh
or bigger Focus um it changing Behavior
Uh it has potential negative side
effects uh that people may or may not
realize what would you say are the
things that are working or have a shot
to change society for the better Bitcoin
stable coins those are two things you've
mentioned are there other things that
you're like hey there seems to be some
progress here and like if this continues
I could see this having an impact uh in
a positive way or is it really just like
one or two things like a Bitcoin and a
stable
coin
um so I find dpin to be very
interesting um using a token economy to
incentivize real world behavior and
actions I find that to be very
interesting um explain a little bit for
those that don't know pin and like what
what it is with these like physical
infrastructure yeah yeah the I think the
headline project to me is helium which I
think is objectively one of the most
successful projects in crypto history
they ship you know I don't know one
point something million of these pieces
of Hardware people set up these pieces
of hardware and then late last year they
partnered with T-Mobile and you can now
get a $20 a month 5G Wi-Fi plan that is
powered by these Hardware units that
people get paid in these tokens to set
up and operate to provide this 5G Wi-Fi
network um that's very interesting and
you know shipping 1. something million
Hardware units you know that's just a
real short list of any projects that
have ever done anything like that and
providing a $20 month 5G Wi-Fi that's
just real world use case that you know
it's a just a real short list of crypto
projects that have ever done something
like that so I think that's interesting
the the issue that I find with with
these
dpin uh projects is that in in my view
just in my view the these the their
token structures just how does the
supply and demand of the token intersect
with the use case of the technology does
not it looks to me to be susceptible to
blowing a big bubble and then collapsing
a big and collapsing a big bubble and
you know axi Infinity would be kind of
the the headline name from the last
cycle that had that kind of thing and
and you know I've been hopeful dude I
mean you and I talked the first time I
did a podcast with you was fall of 2018
that's a long time ago and I think we
talked a lot about crypto valuation on
that podcast and we have made a
stunningly small amount of progress on
token structures since then and I think
I would I would have just thought we
could have had more interesting
experimentation around token structures
to try and get some Innovation there to
create some more
sustainability in how these tokens act
through different cycles of the market
because you know I think the issue with
a lot of these things is that you blow a
big
bubble and then you know the cycle
broadly tops because the fed you know
starts tightening Bitcoin goes down 50
75% and then these tokens do it down
95% tons of people lose a bunch of money
you torch a bunch of the community uh
members and like in a lot of cases the
projects fall apart and they basically
can't make it out the other side of that
so there's just a lack of sustainability
through there and I would just hope that
at some point we could get more
Innovation around that but it looks like
the main Innovation around like token
structure that we have done this cycle
has been the introduction of points uh
you know leading to airdrops you know
which is this is just right down the
middle of the Fairway of Ponzi that
is not sustainable it is just not a
sustainable you know goto Market
customer
acquisition you know beyond a pump and D
like it's just it does not strike me as
very sustainable so and it looks like
that's what we've done that's what we're
leading with this next cycle so so uh
again I think that um this is a perfect
example uh there's a lot of early stage
startups uh who I mean Uber just turned
their first profit right and I remember
uh being in San Francisco Uber and lft
or in the war lft's got the pink uh
mustaches on the front of the cars you
could literally get across town in San
Francisco for like $3 it was wild you're
like I press the button on my phone
somebody picks me up and takes me and
they cost $3 I'm never doing anything
else like this is amazing and what they
were doing is they were just burning the
hell out of VC dollars it was a war of
uh trying to acquire users pay whatever
it took and the promise was they were
going to stay forever now if you go and
you use Uber today
it's expensive right I mean the other
day uh it was pouring rain outside I was
being a little soft you know you know
what and uh I had to go like 15 blocks I
ordered a uber it's 20 bucks yeah and it
was so expensive that it almost made me
be like you know what I don't have an
umbrella with me but like I might just
walk and get soaking wet because it's
the principle of not paying the $20
right and so like there was like this
unsustainable thing and they basically
were like Let's Race to get enough users
to get to the point where we can turn a
profit now Uber made it we work did not
right and we can go through a bunch of
these and most companies do not make it
and so I do Wonder like how many of
these projects or or uh organizations
are trying to be the Uber that takes 15
20 years like they'll eventually get
there um and this idea of like creating
a token somehow gives you like a balance
sheet or a treasury that then you don't
have to raise Capital like you have this
thing that you can use as a currency
versus no actually these guys are all
full of this is a completely stupid
way approaching it and there is no
escaping out the other side right and so
what you're actually doing is you're
wasting time you're burning people and
like it ends up being this really
negative uh kind of
approach I I think you bring up a good
point I think my push back against that
would be you know show me the product
Market fit in crypto that is in the same
ballpark as
Uber you know there just that is just an
incredibly short list and I think if we
had a dozen different applications that
you were seeing very real adoption on
that my view around maybe some of the
unsustainability of the token structures
like I would I would maybe feel
differently about that but it's like
it's like not only does it seem like we
haven't gotten the token structures
right on a lot of this stuff but also
buy and large the overwhelming situation
is is you know either products that
never ship or products that ship and
have no demand you know or you know
solutions that are just looking around
for a problem basically and that that is
you know overwhelmingly the
characterization of enduser applications
um in crypto and there is there's
there's one caveat that I I did mention
in the Tweet thread that I I want to
mention here as well too I think there's
certainly technologists in this space um
more technology focused people that
would say we still don't have cheap
abundant safe
reliable fast block space on L1 smart
contracts we still don't have that been
trying to get it for eight years still
don't have it but you know for X Y and Z
reason this is the cycle that we are
finally going to have cheap abundant
reliable fast safe blockchain
transactions and that it's a field of
dreams if you build it they will come
type of situation once you have that
that like these use cases are going to
magically appear from a cornfield you
know like sches Joe Jackson in Field of
Dreams right and maybe that's true maybe
that's not I think that I pay enough
attention to this space that if that
were to happen that I would like be able
to see that on the horizon because I
just kind of pay attention to the space
and I don't see things that are like
super convincing from that perspective
this cycle and maybe it just means that
like this is the cycle that we get the
the the block space finally and then
maybe it takes the next cycle to then
people be like oh it's finally here and
people start building a bunch of end
user applications so then maybe you know
you fast forward 2028 and uh you know
you get uh you know you finally get
those those enduser applications that
really you know get product Market fit
and it's like you know maybe that's
what's going on when you see uh these
products um I I think that the lack of
product Market fit is a uh uh a good
proxy for like what the actual problem
is right or or maybe it just is the
problem um how do you view Bitcoin in
light of uh that perspective and and
I'll give you a good example so Bitcoin
as a store of value I think most people
are like yep check the box like seems to
be working as a store of value for
people both in terms of price seems to
be that's why people are adopting it um
and seems to now have seeped from retail
institu like uh kind of corporates
financial organizations and now even
starting to get into some of the nation
states you know slowly but but getting
there electronic cash is the promise of
the white paper I don't actually think
that people would all agree that you can
check that box yet stable coins have
more transaction volume uh you know if
bitcoin's price is going to go up in the
future why would I use it today like you
you hear all these critiques and so like
does Bitcoin have product Market fit and
if Bitcoin does or does not I think that
actually is somewhat of a telling sign
for the rest of the market because most
people look at Bitcoin as like the most
successful of all these
tokens yeah that's a good question you
know I think the first thing I'd say in
response to that is that I I actually
wouldn't be too worried I think a
Bitcoin is being so different than any
other crypto asset in existence I I
really do I just it's in a category by
itself
self in my view it does not compete with
other you know I guess maybe you could
say that it competes with stable coins
but I think it is it's firmly lost to
stable coins and I wouldn't expect that
to change and I think I'm still okay
with that and that that doesn't make me
like too super worried about Bitcoin I
am still wor you know I am still waiting
on you know it does seem like lightning
you know it looks like lightning is kind
of having uh you know it's not what
people thought it was going to be
um explain that more in terms of like
where do you think it's missing the
mark Capital efficiency it's my
understanding that the capital
efficiency incentives just make it
um
uh you know just not as useful is the
way people were thinking um but I was
waiting for basically like maker built
on top of lightning where you like it's
just like you stake your BTC you borrow
a stable coin against it you pay some
reasonable rate of interest on that as
long as you pay back the Stables plus
the interest you get your BTC back it's
locked in a smart contract if it goes
down you know if priceing of BTC goes
down enough against you then you get
liquidated pretty straight and I've been
like waiting for that product and that
struck me as a massively better
like that's a product that can go
compete against stable coins basic I
mean it is a stable coin you're right
but it's like that idea made a lot more
sense to me and I you know and there
there is obviously wrapped BTC and you
know WRA BTC does have you know there's
real market cap around that um but uh
for for
Bitcoin you know I I think that the fact
that it doesn't change much it's very
hard to change is part of its value
proposition so I don't worry about that
um I think
that I know that there
is
innovation that is getting funded for
you know l2s and building on top of
Bitcoin to a greater degree than you
know I don't know maybe ever in in
bitcoin's history that like the these
projects are getting funded and that
there's ation that people are getting
interested in and that there's you know
there's this modular versus monolithic
blockchain um uh argument that's going
debate that's going on in crypto right
now I think it's going to be one of the
headline situations for this coming
cycle about uh you know modularity and
this idea of sort of data availability
and separating data availability from
consensus and there's this view that
like maybe you could use Bitcoin as the
data availability layer um and then you
do the computation on uh these other
blockchains and and and uh Bitcoin could
maybe be this kind of foundational part
of the of the this modular blockchain
thesis you know I'm you can get way
smarter guys than me to come on here and
talk to you about the minutia around all
that uh I think that's worth paying
attention to
overall Bitcoin is pristine
collateral um I've I like that moniker
I've liked that moniker for a few years
um the US dollars is the world Reserve
currency but um us treasuries are the
collateral foundation of the Global
Financial system and this is a debt
Laden Global Financial system so the
collateral foundation for a debt Laden
Financial system makes a huge difference
and you know I think objectively the
investment case for us treasuries over a
multi-decade timeline is a challenged
investment thesis but then when you go
look someplace else where we go okay
what else could we use for the
collateral Foundation of this debt Laden
Global Financial system uh that you
really run out of places to look
immediately because uh the US has the
best monetary policy house on a really
shitty monetary policy block and uh like
we're not going to use ECB debt we're
not to use jgbs we're not you know it's
like you run out of like what else would
we use and then eventually you kind of
turn to bitcoin you're like oh maybe
Bitcoin could be this and it's like
that's certainly not the kind of thing
that's going to happen overnight but I
think if Bitcoin just kind of makes
chips away at that you know pristine
collateral uh uh competing against
treasuries for the collateral foundation
of the Global Financial system over the
course of this decade and into the next
that like obviously if that works then
you know we're going to 100,000 and then
200,000 and then 500,000 and then a
million dollars of Bitcoin like you know
it's just like whatever you know the
market value of of all the treasuries in
existence is you know I don't know what
the number is it's like 15 trillion 20
trillion or something so
um yeah one thing I want to ask you
sorry to go back just a little bit just
because you're a social media power user
have you played around on foraster have
you spent time with foraster not a ton
of time um early on uh I looked at it
and um I think they did exactly what you
have to do which is uh do none of the
growth hacks right like you know after
being around so many of these um you
know I helped uh create apps that once
more in the App Store like all all these
different things the number one thing
that people mistake is all the growth
hacks that work in fintech B2B uh you
know software all that stuff you cannot
do those when it comes to social
networks because you have to allow The
Social Network to actually form it's
almost like like an evolution and so if
you um very similar to a company think
of early stage company you can suffocate
a company by not giving them enough
Capital you can or uh I'm sorry you can
starve them by not giving them enough
Capital you can suffocate them by giving
them too much Capital the same thing can
happen with a social network you can
starve it by not having enough users
show up but you can suffocate a social
network by having everyone show up at
once there's nothing really there yet
there's not enough content there's not
enough connections the connections
aren't real um people don't really know
what is the culture of it what is the
conversations what am I supposed to be
doing here all this stuff and you only
really kind of get one shot and so if
you see what they've done is they have
that really nice exponential user curve
and they I mean they spent years I think
Dan I think the first time I talked to
him was maybe 2018 2019 something like
that when he was first starting this
thing there was nobody using it and most
entrepreneurs would get frustrated by
that but I think he understood no you
have to let the community kind of build
itself and allow that organic growth and
then that's where you get the breakout
compounding you never know when it'll
hit but it hit for them and I think I
saw recently like in the last like two
weeks they 10x the user base or 10x like
daily active users like yeah but wasn't
it off of like an incredibly low base
of course I think now they have like
60,000 daily actives right or or
whatever but but the but the point being
that like at one point they had 10
people on The Social Network and they
weren't like let's get to 100,000 users
tomorrow it was like let's go find the
11th person who's the right person yeah
right and and I the way that I found out
about is Dan literally was like I will
personally on board you and do a call
and like he was just methodically going
through the right people adding them to
the network and so uh one of the things
if I was to critique crypto in general
uh everyone has such impatience which
feeds into like the financial nihilism
feeds into like I need the 10x 100x coin
Etc but if you're building a product you
have to understand is this a product
where urgency is the dominant you know
posture or actually in the case of
social networks patience is really
important and if you remember Facebook
yes it grew quickly on Harvard's campus
but no one else could sign up except for
on Harvard's campus it was like a
limited you know growth and then they
added one other campus and so they
allowed this thing to kind of build and
then eventually it was a huge deal when
they let people not with edu emails sign
up but that was like I think if I
remember correctly three or four years
after they
started and so it's same thing here is
like how do you just allow patience to
be the dominant posture when you're
building that type of product versus
maybe something else you actually want
it to go as quick as possible now the
last thing I'll say is Bitcoin had the
exact same benefit I do not believe
Bitcoin can get disrupted today because
today if a coin launched and wanted to
be a global Reserve currency electronic
cash you know whatever it doesn't have
time to fester and kind of grow
organically because everyone's looking
for the next coin so the fact that
people had ignorance when Bitcoin was
released in 2009 was a huge benefit and
so it kind of like went up the ladder
and then pulled the ladder up behind it
for that that use case strongly agree
because people can't it's just like
we're togen to degenerate anyone who's
creating anything is going to tell
someone and that person is gonna turn
around and yell to everyone else on
telegram or on Twitter like yo I found
it and it actually will screw up the
building out of the network today's
episode is brought to you by Bas Bas is
making it their mission to bring a
billion people on chain what exactly is
BAS it's a layer two offering a seamless
experience for both Builders and users
with near zero gas fees and Rapid
transaction ction speeds Bas is shaping
the future of the onchain world Bas is a
canvas for everyone with hundreds of
apps in the ecosystem whether you're an
emerging Creator a seasoned developer or
someone exploring the onchain space for
the first time bases designed to bring
your ideas to life so if you're looking
for a platform where the future of
onchain is being built daily Bas is your
destination join in and make onchain the
next online learn more at b.org or
follow along on Twitter at build onbase
again that's at build on base to see
cool things to do on chain every single
day yeah yeah yeah cuz I just going back
to the just the use cases you know I
think decentralized social media is a
interesting use case that is worth
Innovation worth funding
Innovation um you know friend Tech had
its moment last year you know looks like
it was probably a flash in the pan at
this point you know it was this kind of
marginal incremental Innovation relative
to kind of what else had been out there
so I think it's good and I wouldn't be
surprised at all it would almost be my
base case that at some point you know
you get incremental Innovation on
incremental Innovation on incremental
Innovation and then it's like you know
maybe the great great grandchild of
friend Tech or something like that ends
up being the thing that gets you know 50
million users or whatever the number is
um so I you know I do find that
interesting um and that just kind of the
fundamentals around crypto and like you
know just being able to connect with
users connect with fans in this kind of
unique way um you know trying to
monetize and incentivize the things like
that seems like a you know a hotbed for
this kind of technology and for and for
you know what crypto represents I just
don't see something in existence today
where I'm like that's the thing that's
going to be 50 million users yeah I mean
if you also think um you know look
there's uh uh foraster there's Doo
there's there's a bunch of these I think
that um people are trying it but uh I
wonder how much of crypto has the what I
call the AI problem so right now there
is an explosion of AI companies that uh
they're smart you know hardworking uh
people who say oh my God new technology
I got to go build an AI company but
actually where we're seeing value acrew
is companies who are solving a real
problem use AI technology
internally but it's not necessarily an
AI business right it it's kind of like a
company that existed and then all a su
the internet comes along like I'm gonna
use the internet but I'm not necessarily
just going to go do something because
there's this new tool it's not a hammer
looking for a nail right it's it's a
business that says hey there's a new
technology that will help me do what I
was already doing better cheaper faster
whatever the AI companies that seem to
be really winning like I mean Facebook
is a great example right you obviously
Amazon Google like you see these
companies integrating this stuff and
those are the big guys but there's also
small companies that are figuring this
out as well is crypto and AI actually
going to fit into the same hole when you
we zoom out you know 20 years from now
and we say man all the people who tried
to build a crypto product actually were
thinking about it wrong they should have
built a product that solved the problem
and if the crypto rails made it easier
then they used it but they made that
evaluation the same way that they would
make the evaluation over should we use
uh a SQL database or something else it's
just a tool toolbox and so like rather
than say I'm a crypto entrepreneur you
should say I'm an entrepreneur in
healthcare by the way the best database
to use is a SQL database the best uh you
know hosting site is this my cloud
provider is AWS and oh by the way the
way we do this feature or this thing
uses crypto rails but it's kind of in
more so than it is like I'm a crypto
founder I have a crypto company yep one
thing along those lines that definitely
caught my
attention was last year BK the meme coin
on salana you probably followed it did
you did you see the point where the
salana Saga phone had enough Bonk
airdrops to it that it paid for the
phone yes and then the and then the
phone sold out out in 48 hours like
right in the midst like it's like you
know I don't think they moved that many
phones of this thing right first and
then it just kind of sat there nobody
was really talking about it I can't
remember when they first launched the
phone but you know we went through the
bare Market people kind of stopped
talking about this thing and then it was
like Bonk started running and then at
some point they were like oh all the
Saga phones get you know x amount of
Bonk and then this thing is you know I
don't know it was up like 9,000 per or
some and it's like at some point on
the run it was like oh the phone's the
phone's a th000 bucks oh you can get a
$1,000 worth of B on the phone and then
the phone sold out in 48 hours and now
it looks like I think because because
the now the phone's getting other aird
drops as well too and now it's looking
like those phones the phone cost $1,000
and it's going to get like 10,000 plus
dollars worth of free that gets
aird dropped on it because now it got um
some nft that's now like you know you
can sell this thing for how like a
thousand or 2,000 bucks or whatever got
some jeto or some Jupiter you know this
that and the other and uh that did and
they also were like oh not long after
they sold out the first phone they're
like hey we're doing a salana vers Saga
version 2 phone and like I don't know if
they were going to do a version two or
not prior to that happening maybe they
were I don't know but it's like and I
just was thinking that a traditional
like web 2 company or any kind of
traditional marketing advertis in
company had to have looked at that and
been like well that's pretty
interesting so we're talking about
things that uh Bitcoin maximalist don't
talk about right they don't they don't
give a about this stuff um I think
that if somebody was to talk to you and
I five years ago we would have been much
closer to bitcoin maximalist than uh
maybe we are today and some of that is
uh probably driven by uh what is the
financial return what is the current
development and adoption and also uh
it's not an either or it's not a a a net
um you know like a zero sum game it's
much more of a positive sum game Bitcoin
won in This Global store value game and
there will be other things and I I'm at
the point now where like anyone who
thinks that the other things are all
going to zero is probably actually
doesn't even believe that they're just
saying it because it sounds good right
but also uh they're just not paying
attention
so
yeah are people the most Ardent you know
kind of Hardcore Bitcoin maximalists
have they locked themselves into
becoming the new gold bugs and like you
know a friend said this to me and I
can't get it out of my head is Michael
sailor the new Peter Schiff is the you
know is the uh the gold bugs who are
constantly saying Doom is right around
the corner buy gold get your physical
gold you know build out your shelter uh
the the world is
ending does Bitcoin have a issue with
potentially entering into uh you know
that realm is is that a possible pathway
that Bitcoin Max was doesn't mean that
uh they have to go that way they should
just be aware of not transitioning into
an area where you're not mentally
flexible enough to be able to evaluate
everything
else well I do think that there where
Bitcoin sits right now that there
certainly a real potential that it kind
of I know this sounds weird that it like
stops being a
crypto that it just like like Crypton
native Capital like that's not the
capital that is going to take this thing
from A1 trillion dollar to two trillion
to five trillion and that this that and
Beyond and then the crypto native
Capital kind of looks at that and
they're like oh like it doesn't have
enough meat on the bone like there's not
enough meat left on the bone for the
returns of this thing and that now that
we've got spot Bitcoin ETFs passive
flows um this thing over the next you
know coming year and then years after
that that it's just it's playing a
totally different game in terms of of
asset allocation and like asset
Gathering type of uh situation and that
the returns and I talked about this I've
written about this before the return you
know it's like Bitcoin is probably
levered NASDAQ returns with like a call
option on the world Reserve currency the
next World Reserve currency and then
it's like and you can actually look at
it like you know you can look at it like
that and it's and I think it's just
because that tech stocks have the same
similar type of relationship with global
liquidity that Bitcoin has um and that
does just kind of put it into a category
by itself and you know
Bitcoin
maximalists you
know I mean I don't know I don't know
what your viewership is exactly like
these days but like you
know from cycle to cycle you you rewind
four years
ago and then fast forward to
today you know the people waving the
Bitcoin flag the hardest you did not get
an upgrade on those people over the last
four years and you can you know disagree
with me about that you can get mad at me
if you feel that way that's my view you
know I won't go in a bunch more detail
around that but like um I'll take I'll
take it a step further for you you don't
have to say it uh Bitcoin has now
escaped the video game and when it gets
pulled into the traditional Financial
World it gets overlaid with politics and
what do you get rewarded for in politics
extremism and so the more that you pull
people hard left hard right they yell
and scream at each other that's what
happened to bitcoin you get rewarded in
Bitcoin for being an extremist right and
an extremist not in any other sense than
like you're an extreme Bitcoin
maximalist the more extreme you are the
more that you know a certain way that
the way you adhere to the religion um in
some weird way it's like uh you know um
if you are the uh traditionalist right
then you get rewarded uh with social
capital and I'm not even saying that's
anything that's bad right it's just it's
just calling it what it is and and kind
of how uh it is developed um what is
funny about it or or unique about it and
interesting is uh when you look at these
surveys it's like 85 to 90% of
bitcoiners hold another asset so what
ends up happening is there are some
people within the community that are
playing the status game and then there
are some people who are playing a
capital allocation game right and uh
when you meet people sometimes you don't
know sometimes you definitely know right
and and I think that there is this very
unique development where again you know
it just it seared in my head when my
friend who by the way my friend is a uh
Bitcoin critic right when he said the
thing about like Peter shiff and Michael
saor are the same person but his point
was if Peter Schiff came out tomorrow
and said gold is bad gold would tank
right he's like if I sold all my gold
Michael sailor actually I think would be
even worse yeah and Michael Michael's
done a fantastic job like one of the
things that Michael has really done I
think is he has helped sheered in an
entirely new cohort of people that he
basically said come in the the water's
warm it's okay right you can come check
this out and so he's been this huge net
positive but if you're sitting in
Michael sailor's seat if all of a sudden
the returns start to go down again I
think he's buying it to protect the
capital on his balance sheet so it's
still gonna check that box but now where
does the future growth of the firm come
from in the
future right and and again it's unclear
what that return profile looks like if
Bitcoin goes down to a 10% annualized
return that's probably still pretty good
right it's better than holding cash if
it goes down to a 5 per return right is
that still good enough I don't know
right and I'm sure he's thinking about
these things and trying to figure out
hey what are the other things we can do
to drive cash flow Etc but I do think
that um the ground underneath the
industry has been shifting and your
point about like does Bitcoin have
enough meat on the bone I've said for a
long time the reason why I liked Bitcoin
was because when I would go talk to
hardcore Wall Street people they would
say Bitcoin is the riskiest thing in my
portfolio but then I would go talk to
like the dgen you know pseudonym on
Twitter and they're like I don't own
Bitcoin because that's Boomer coin yeah
and so if you're like you know I'm kind
of a cowboy but I'm also like not gonna
go speculate on Zen coin yeah and
actually Bitcoin is like the you know
it's the riskiest thing in the
conservative people's portfolio it's the
conservative thing in the risky people's
portfolio so like that actually is
pretty attractive to a public company
right who wants to be on the forward
edge of this so it's a very interesting
Dynamic that we don't have the answers
to yet as to like where we're going yeah
do you think we're going to get another
sailor type of situation this cycle or
or a Tesla type of
situation I think that sailor actually
had an impact I don't think Tesla
actually had an impact um in terms of
like they reiterated the trend uh
blocked it or Square did the same thing
but uh I think the 0o to one of the
first public company that wasn't a
crypto company to do it was like 80 90%
of the value of like that happening um
and so I don't think at this point it
really matters like if Apple tomorrow
went and said we're putting Bitcoin on
the balance sheet like yes there would
be some short-term price you know
movement whatever but I think now the
market is kind of like desensitized over
the medium to long term that like they
just have priced in like of course every
you know these companies are going to do
some percentage of it I think the only
really really big zero to one last one
is uh a sizable developed Nation either
government or Sovereign right um and I I
asked myself like what is that threshold
obviously if some of the largest you
know Middle Eastern Sovereign wealth
funds did it that'd be a big deal um but
like El Salvador I think rallied the
Bitcoin Community I don't think actually
the market gave it any credit outside of
the Bitcoin Community like I think
people are kind of just like whatever it
doesn't work like they didn't do
anything and they just completely
discount it and so it's like okay that
was a small nation like what is the
threshold right you know if Italy did it
would anyone care if Spain did it if
India did it right like like where is
that kind of Tipping Point where all of
a sudden everyone pays attention and
Michael uh Michael sailor and Michael
strategy were very unique in that like
they weren't a massive company but they
were a multi-billion dollar company it
was big enough yeah and he articulated
it in a way that I think it was that
Tipping Point he got the zero one and it
was incredibly valuable to uh to the
community and obviously drove a lot of
people uh to take a look at the asset
yeah yeah great mouthpiece for sure yeah
really yeah really good mouthpiece yeah
I think the El
Salvador I mean it's my understanding
that the Bitcoin like things are much
much much better in El Salvador since bu
um got a you know got into power but I
don't think really any of that has to do
with Bitcoin is my understanding and
that and I don't have the details around
that but I asked somebody the other day
because I was writing about it in my
monthly and I asked somebody that you
and I both know that would know like
how's the El Salvador Bitcoin thing
going and they're like it's not you know
it's not basically um so but it's also
like uh in that and that's actually a
pretty good uh use case I think where
like most of the people who were in
government who went and said we are
going to embrace
this there was bigger talk than there
was action in a lot of cases right so
like I remember at one point Greg Abbott
uh in Texas the governor um mayor Suarez
in Miami and Eric Adams the mayor in New
York City were all like competing on
who's gonna be the head honcho like
capital of Bitcoin in America right and
like you know the mayor of Miami who uh
to his credit was very early to he I
would argue he kicked it off right at
one point said I'm goingon to take my
next paycheck in Bitcoin and then the
mayor of New York's like I'm going to
take my first three paychecks and it was
like all right like we got a little bit
of you know like a dick measuring
contest going on here but like okay
um when you see that happening I know
for specifically in Mii because I've
talked to him he ran into roadblock
after roadblock after roadblock trying
to get anything done in terms of buying
Bitcoin for the balance sheet paying
employees in Bitcoin you know any of
this stuff and so like you have to
remember government is still
bureaucratic one person it's really hard
to change but
buelli as the president got a lot more
executive power and so I do think that
it's like kind of nation states are
different than cities and states where
uh the president is able to get things
done even if there is resistance from
those around them in a way that you just
can't do at other levels of government
yeah I agree with that yeah if you look
at um the macro environment you
mentioned earlier Bitcoin is a trade on
global liquidity isn't all of crypto or
do you think Bitcoin is unique in that
way uh no I think all of crypto
is it's just that
the bitcoin's relationship is
more Lindy a lot more Lindy it's it's
it's it's multicycle Lindy like three up
one
down that is accurate for Bitcoin it's
accurate for the crypto Market broadly
but then when you try and drill down
into specific crypto assets it's uh it
falls apart um and I think my the way I
always explain this is looking at
tokens that can make new highs against
BTC in the cycle after they started
trading all kinds of tokens make highs
you know they're introduced in the bear
they're introduced you know at the end
of the last bull or whatever and then
they're first bull market the first you
know up three cycle they Skyrocket you
know bitcoin's up you know whatever 500%
these things are up 9,000 per or
whatever the number is and then you've
got the down one year Bitcoin does it
down 75% these tokens do it down you
know
95% and then you come back to the next
cycle and they pump again but they won't
make a new high in BTC terms and um
I think Doge and xrp ironically are the
I believe the only two that made higher
highs against BTC in the cycle after
they were introduced which you know
there's a lot of irony irony that it's
it's those two names but I think that's
you know and and and and for Bitcoin
maximist or for people that would say
just have all your crypto exposure being
in Bitcoin this is that like what I just
described is the number one thing to
hang your hat on for that where you go
do you have the time to pick the
coins that are going to pump and pick
the right part of the cycle and sell in
time can you do all of that while you
work your day job or you know whatever
right and that's very hard to do and and
and and it's a great point you know for
it's like it's pretty crazy like for as
much hype as eth had La last cycle for
the returns that it had ebtc wasn't
higher than it was in January 2018 it's
pretty crazy what you're highlighting is
the difference between saving and
investing right in my opinion like yeah
saving in Bitcoin and just set it forget
it right and basically just hold it um
is no different than decades ago when
people would save in Gold I always you
know tell a story of uh in India the
culture is like you never sell your
grandparents gold it gets passed down
from generation to generation and you
just saved right same thing uh I think
with Bitcoin and it is you're you're the
line you're drawing is like you save in
Bitcoin and then there's like
speculating and investing and everything
else by the way buying birk Shear stock
is speculating as well right but like
the investing game is very hard the
saving game is all about just discipline
and frankly like a lack of e ego right
it's just keep doing the same thing now
what becomes very interesting though is
as you look at let's take an eth another
thing I've thought a lot about recently
uh ethereum's maximalist or Amateur hour
compared to Doge and xrp think of the
think how think of how rabid Dogecoin
and xrp kind of uh maximalists are they
rivaled the maximalism of
bitcoiners that's why I think those
assets have the unique kind of
performance that compared to an ethereum
Etc because actually what we found was
the bitcoiners were
missionaries the eth users were
mercenaries and a lot of them jump ship
when came around it was cheaper and
faster usdt jumped to Tron yeah because
it was cheaper and faster and so what
you end up getting again it goes back to
saving and investing you can use
mercenary versus missionary right like
there's all these Frameworks that you
can use to really uh highlight the idea
that um the performance of these assets
really is driven by global liquidity
plus like what is the community and to a
stock investor like that sounds insane
but if you think of like that Community
component the assets that have surprised
people people to the upside have tended
to have a very unique culture to them
and be much more missionary than
mercenary and so people don't jump and
then the other thing that becomes really
interesting is like Bitcoin is not the
first digital currency you know I wrote
recently about like it's the a product
of 40 Years of
R&D ethereum actually is the first
blockchain with smart
contracts and so if you said to me right
now gun to your head pick which one's
the AOL it's ethereum Bitcoin doesn't
have competition to be the digital
decentralized Global store of value it's
the winner it's the king and there is
nobody who's coming for it so far right
you and I could spend 10 minutes
rattling off all the layer ones that are
coming for ethereum yeah and you can
even argue like did they lose did they
lose ground you know the price can still
go up but if others go up more like
that's still an L to a degree yeah and
so it's just a very very unique
difference because again I go back five
years ago you and I couldn't have these
conversations because none of this was
true now the world has changed
drastically in the last five years
yep yeah no no it's a good point I I
think it's gonna be you know salana it's
gonna be fascinating to watch salana
this coming cycle I think salana has a
chance
to make higher highs in BTC terms this
cycle uh to you know break that Trend or
you know enter into this very small Club
I think think
Solana's um Community is
noteworthy and that community's ability
to stick together and stick around after
FTX collapsed was noteworthy and
surprising surprising to me um and you
know even characteriz you know I think
salana was up 900% last year and it's
like
characterizing how that happened
you know it's impressive and I'm not I'm
still not sure I completely understand
it um but part of it is certainly the
community of users the community of
developers um part of it is um is
the uh difficulty that the space
continues to have to provide cheap safe
abundant fast block space um and
reliable block space and because that
continues to be hard to get and salana
made tangible improvements to the
network functionality you know their
their outage yesterday
notwithstanding uh but they you know
they did make real improvements to it I
think I think that was probably part of
it as well too I I don't know this off
the top of my head but my guess is that
same thing I talked about with alts
versus BTC not making higher BTC terms
in the cycle after they were introduced
my guess is all competitor alt ones
versus eth that probably holds true uh
that same situation I I don't know I
don't have my computer up right in front
of me but um maybe Tron I don't know if
Tron made a higher Tron eth maybe that
made a higher high in the cycle after
but it's like it's a Sim it's kind of a
similar type of like you know it's it's
a that is a quantitative metric that
helps you tell a qualitative fundamental
story about how the market is thinking
through value you know assigning value
AC crewing value across these various
different names you want to hear a crazy
statistic yeah if micro strategy had
bought ethereum instead of Bitcoin
they'd have more money right now yeah oh
yeah I knew that and so if you think of
it from that perspective uh the time in
which we have this conversation matters
because I don't actually think that will
be true if we talk about this in five
years right like like it like Bitcoin
would have been the better choice over
10 years but over the last three
years it's kind of and it's not like oh
they'd have 10% more like I think it's
like bitcoin's up 4X and ethereum's
still up like 6X or something right and
so given the size of capital that
they've deployed and what it's worth
today like it's like a billion or two
billion dollar difference yeah um and so
like if I'm a eth maximalist I'm I'm
yelling and screaming about that if I'm
a Bitcoin maximalist I'm kind of saying
like chill out you know give us some
time right and like over the long run
let's see what happens but I do think
that um we've now entered a world where
it's not 2017 2018 like buy crypto and
like sit on your hands and like you're
going to get rich we've now entered a
game of like you actually have to do
some sophisticated analysis and I think
that's why bitcoiners like the single
greatest thing that they could tell
people is like opt out of the
speculation game and just
save right like like yeah you are not
you're not Warren Buffett you're not you
know name your favorite macro Trader
just save and that is a very very
different message than I think what is
happening in the rest of the market to
your point like sets Bitcoin aside
um because the digital hyperconnected
world is just making people more
impatient they're going to make mistakes
like all all the the issues that we know
um and so I think it gets uh pretty
interesting Before I Let You Go uh how
are you guys allocated today like
that'll tell us a lot kind of how you
think about the
future oh gosh I got to be really
careful about that um or what are the
themes maybe that you guys are
allocating to so not actual assets but
like the themes that you think are
interesting yeah
so uh eeky is mostly a Quant fund um and
we have historically focused on BTC and
eth and because that's where we've been
able to find you know predictive power
in quantitative data um and that
continues to be where our the large
majority of our efforts are today our
mandate is very broad we can kind of do
you know in terms of like what our
offering documents say we can kind of do
like sort of whatever we want to with
very little limitation so we have
historically um you know had room for
and spent time on you know qualitative
liquid Venture type of stuff that is not
just you know combing through enormous
amounts of raw data to find predictive
power you know type of stuff
um and we continue to do that um and you
know I find the deepend space broadly um
very interesting I think it's going to
be in a cycle that may have a real dirth
of um actual adoption I think it has a
chance to be the brightest spot of
actual adoption
actual you know use cases that you can
see you know solving real world problems
for real people um and I think that it
makes sense to me that in a universe
where people are starve for that kind of
thing that they're going to gravitate
towards these projects that can actually
show you know real real user adoption um
yeah I think that's I think that's what
i' would say about it where can with
some people to find you on the internet
or find out more about icky guy if they
want uh Twitter is always good Travis
forcing on Twitter uh there's links to
the fund and and whatnot there I write a
monthly that goes out the first of every
month that that uh people like a lot and
um yeah appreciate the time enjoy the
conversation man I always enjoy uh
listening hopefully uh they don't come
for us but sometimes you just got to
talk about the things that are going on
my friend all right we'll talk soon all
right man